congratulations on this film you are the
moderator with sandra and channing i
mean what drew you to saying yes when
you saw the script it was
what drew me to say yes was sandy and
channing 100 but then the call from my
agents was that sandy sort of you know
personally wanted me involved and it was
so flattering when sandra calls you have
to answer it's great to feel wanted by
sandra bullock right
by someone who like has done it all like
has achieved success at every level in
the industry like it's it was it was it
was an honor i had to
you know fulfill the calling it's so
funny because everyone i talk to about
this film always talks about the
chemistry that sandra and channing had
now you were able to be on set with them
see them behind the scenes so what was
it really like it was truly
so joyous i felt like such a respected
guest in their home but the two of them
really
talk about chemistry literally it's just
the two of them sort of bouncing off
each other in like this most
you know effervescent way they were they
were so good together in channing's wig
i mean wig was so great he was doing
some stunts in that wig in my scene so
um it was great it was very
kinesthetic it was it was beautiful
really quickly i wanted to ask you your
buddy b davidson is out here getting his
girlfriend's name branded on his chest
have you seen it yet i have not seen it
i have not seen it you know i think
that's that's like an intimate thing and
so i you know who am i to demand to see
it it's the new way to show your love
it's very yellow stone-ish getting your
girlfriend's name branded on you
yeah i i've yet to see that show too i'm
just like out of the loop with
everything
it seems
after this now maybe you'll have some
time to go check it out but what do you
make of branding her name on your chest
no
uh it's his body his choice is that how
the saying goes is that the um
application of that phrase no i'm just
kidding uh i think
i i think um you know i'm just like
learning it as the information comes
along with the rest of everybody